[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
on the 3rd of November this year Imran
Khan the former prime minister of
Pakistan survived an assassination
attempt months earlier in April of the
same year he had resigned following a
vote of no confidence in Parliament if
we were talking about any other country
we would say that Pakistan is in a
really worrying political crisis however
this kind of news is almost the norm in
this country Pakistan has been in
political and economic chaos since its
independence but you may be wondering
what does Pakistan matter to me well
visual pelletic viewers Pakistan should
matter to you and a lot for three simple
reasons the first is that is the fifth
most populated country in the planet
with more than 220 million people what's
more is considered one of the few
countries in the world with nuclear
weapons and its nuclear Doctrine is
trigger happy to say the least in theory
it would only take someone invading
their territory for them to be able to
launch a nuclear bomb but wait because
there's still a third reason terrorism
Pakistan has all kinds of scenario
scripts in many cases some which are
supported by the state itself in fact do
you remember where Osama Bin Laden was
killed it was in Pakistan and not just
in any world random Hideout but in the
city of a botabad which to put things in
perspective is the Pakistani Beverly
Hills how could anyone ignore a country
like Pakistan which looks like it could
blow up at any moment the truth is that
it is chilling just thinking about the
fifth most populated country in the
world which also has nuclear weapons and
is plagued by terrorism which might fall
apart the situation in Pakistan is
critical after Decades of instability
they are now on the verge of collapse
but how did Pakistan get to this point
why is it in such Dire Straits and what
is holding it back so badly today we're
going to answer all of these questions
but first let's look at some history
[Music]
the Pakistani Pandora's Box
[Music]
did you know that in Pakistan no prime
minister who has won an election has
ever finished his term in office
Pakistan has been mired in the darkness
of political instability since its
Inception in fact the assassination
attempt on Imran Khan is just one more
event and a long line of Pakistan's
chaotic history and truth be told seeing
how others in the same position have
ended up he's actually been pretty lucky
because do you know how the rest of them
ended up either accused of corruption
and in jail or exiled or even
assassinated like the only female prime
minister the country ever had benazar
Bhutto she was assassinated when she was
running for a third term so I think you
kind of get the idea but let's slow down
a bit to understand why Pakistan is the
way it is you see Pakistan became
independent from the British Empire in
1947 just like India but the Pakistan
you know now is not the Pakistan that
became independent then
[Music]
when Pakistan was liberated from Britain
it was divided into two territories East
Pakistan and West Pakistan that is what
is the Pakistan we know now and
Bangladesh soon ethnic tensions arose
leading to a civil war that eventually
separated the two territories and in
1973 almost two years after the end of
the war Pakistan adopted a new
constitution this constitution
recognizes Islam as the official
religion although it also accepts some
elements of secularism
of course Pakistan is far from a perfect
democracy and in fact it has two major
problems it's security and its political
institutions you see the military
dominates the entire functioning of
society and doesn't miss a beat
logically among its tasks is the
security of the country but its strategy
against the external enemy India is
quite drastic in fact the Army itself
baptized the strategy with the name of
bleeding India with a Thousand Cuts so
what does this consist of very simple
train insurgents and destabilize India
so it's hardly surprising that we come
across news stories like this one
Pakistan trained militant underground
groups to fight against India in Kashmir
former Pakistani president pervez
Musharraf admitted in an interview with
Spiegel but don't think he's only funded
these groups to destabilize India look
at what former prime minister Imran Khan
himself has said the Pakistani army
trained Al-Qaeda and all these groups to
fight in Afghanistan Imran Khan I mean
even the Pakistani leaders themselves do
not deny that they have financed
terrorist groups and who do you think is
being affected now indeed it's Pakistan
thank you
as you can see Pakistan is full of
active terrorist groups which
continuously attack cities and towns in
the country not even the capital
Islamabad is spared and as if there were
not enough the poor citizens of this
country have had to put up with
tremendously unstable governments until
today kudi Taz like the one in 1977 or
in 1999 unrestrained corruption
assassination of politicians in short
and odyssey and guess who they have to
thank for all this exactly you've
guessed it it's the Army again the Army
is taken to removing and installing
prime minister's left and right and many
times with the help of Judges Andrew may
ask why is the army so interested in
Rolling politics for one simple reason
to protect its economic interests you
see the military directly owns more than
50 companies and is believed that
through foundations it has thousands
more companies under its control in a
total the Pakistani military is
reportedly involved in businesses and
Deals which are valued at more than 20
billion dollars and these are not just
any companies but companies that
dominate almost all of the national
markets in which they operate such as
the serial fertilizer or Gas
Distribution markets of course as you
can imagine as soon as they see their
interests in danger they do not not
hesitate to accuse the prime minister of
corruption
[Music]
you need to understand given a country
with so much political instability an
army with crucial companies in the
country acting only to make money along
with a lack of security economic decline
is basically assured and of course if we
add to this the fact that Pakistan
hardly produces anything except from a
few mangoes vegetable oils and trucks
then we have the Ace of aces in fact the
trade balance is really lousy take a
look at this among the three largest
countries on the Indian subcontinent
Pakistan is the worst performer entitled
exports and share of GDP this is an
indicator of its pure openness to the
outside world and the poor
competitiveness of its companies but of
course if this was the extent of
Pakistan's problems we wouldn't be
making this video stay tuned because we
are just getting started
Pakistan's best friend
[Music]
imagine you wanted to put some solar
panels on your house but you had no
money what would you do you would ask
for a loan right well in a way Pakistan
has done the same thing although
switching investment for current
spending because it wanted to provide
public services but it had no money
because this economy could not afford it
it went into debt the country has a debt
as high as 70 of its GDP and I know what
you're going to say let's see 70 does
not seem so high if we compare it to
other countries like Spain for example
which is 120 but the difference is that
Pakistan does not have an economy
developed enough to support such level
of indebtedness the political risk the
lack of public revenue and all of the
problems we have described make one the
demand for Pakistani debt very low and
two the rates at which the country is
financed much higher and if we take into
account these factors less money
available and higher interest rates than
70 percent becomes a real problem in
fact their bonds are rated as junk bonds
because naturally the question is who in
their right mind would lend their money
well apart from the IMF or the World
Bank their best friend is China that's
right the Asian giant is Pakistan's main
creditor
Kristan was one of the first countries
to recognize China in 1951. both had a
common adversary India in fact with the
outbreak of war between India and China
in 1962 the two countries began to
cooperate militarily in recent years
almost 40 percent of China's arms
exports have gone to Pakistan in the
1990s this cooperation was extended to
the economic field and since 2015 they
agreed to create an economic corridor
you know what you're going to ask me is
China really that interested in trading
with a country that can barely support
itself well yes it is and for the reason
why take a look at this map
what you see here is the guadar port
built by China this port would
eventually be China's Lifeline why well
keep looking at our map China buys oil
from Arab countries that oil Travels by
ship and passes along India's coasts at
any time India the United States or one
of its allies could cut off that Transit
it would be enough to close these three
straights you stay on the screen to
block all oil transit to China however
if these ships dock in Pakistan they
could ship the oil over land in other
words India or the United States could
not have such an easy time cutting off
Transit and let's see this is going to
be very good for China but what does
Pakistan get out of it well about 62
billion dollars in infrastructure
construction projects if Pakistan wants
to have a productive economy it needs
ports railroads and Roads and very few
would dare to put the money on the table
to build those things the reason lies in
one word terrorism
Pakistan is plagued by terrorist groups
Al-Qaeda the Taliban pro-independence
group's list is endless and all this
means that even China has problems when
it comes to building a port check this
out Pakistan Chinese Nationals among
four killed in Karachi blast to give you
an idea China has even proposed to wall
off the entire Port of guardar to
protect it from terrorist groups and all
this explains why these loans from China
come with higher interest rates than
those from the IMF while the IMF charges
an interest rate of 3 China charges
about 6.5 in other words Pakistan is
very unproductive has a lot of risks and
at the same time maintains a Savage debt
with the IMF and with China and you may
ask how are they getting along with the
United States well as you can imagine
the relationship status is it's
complicated on the one hand the United
States is the main market for Pakistani
products of the few goods that Pakistan
exports Uncle Sam is the most
significant buyer on the political front
however relations are not good
[Music]
during the Cold War Pakistan was an ally
against the Soviet Union in those years
Washington trained Insurgent groups to
fight against the Soviets however
everything changed when Pakistan started
its nuclear program overnight the White
House cut off all arm supplies to
Pakistan but without a doubt the biggest
bone of contention is Terrorism Pakistan
is a Haven for a lot of terrorist groups
think about it Osama Bin Laden was holed
up in a nice neighborhood on the
outskirts of a botabad his house was
just over a kilometer from the Pakistan
Military Academy so they were
practically neighbors but of course no
one knew anything what's more when the
Navy Seals entered Bin Laden's house
they had to invade Pakistani airspace
this did not amuse the Pakistani
government in the slightest but all of
this is a topic for another video today
we're going to focus on the crisis in
this country as we were saying Pakistan
is up to its eyebrows in debt what's
more they want to pay off the debt they
already have with more debt as you can
imagine this is the perfect recipe for a
collapse of Galactic proportions all it
took was one big surprise event to end
up bringing down the whole country and
the last few years have been full of
surprise events and we're gonna look at
them
no
Khan the big disappointment
[Music]
have you seen the videos we have
dedicated to the energy crisis in Europe
have you remember in recent months the
slogan in Europe has been we will pay
whatever it takes to fill our gas tanks
that means that many LNG ships Bound for
Asia turned around and went to Europe
where they were paid much more all of
this is relatively good news for Europe
but there is a clear loser the Asian
countries that are running out of gas
and who has been one of the biggest
losers in this crisis that's right
Pakistan you see in these last four
years Pakistan has undergone several
political and economic changes the major
political parties The People's Party and
the now as Pakistani Muslim League have
seen their dominance in jeopardy
foreign
to give you an idea of the People's
Party is the party that has ruled
Pakistan for the most time to make a
quick comparison we could say that they
are the closest thing to a western
Social Democratic party the Muslim
League in contrast would be the
equivalent of a conservative party
however in 2018 the classic political
Outsider called forth to Brit with
bipartisanship appeared the typical
charismatic leader who promises Wonders
on the campaign Trail in this case it
was all about a cricket star which is
the national sport in Pakistan exactly
we are talking about Imran Khan Imran
Khan's party ran in the 2018 elections
promising to improve the economy and
build a welfare state under Islamic
socialism what's more as the country's
two major parties were riddled with
corruption he took the opportunity to
also run on an anti-corruption message
and he ended up winning unfortunately
luck was not with him in his presidency
shortly after winning he had to face his
first crisis the covert crisis you
already know that the covert crisis
stopped the entire global economy in its
tracks and Pakistan was not going to be
an exception and if its economy had
already been stagnant the covert crisis
would not make it easy for it to improve
but wait a minute because that was just
the beginning what is the main source of
energy in Pakistan's Energy Mix exactly
it's natural gas
[Music]
however this country has no
International pipeline connection they
have tried to build one with Russia and
another with Iran but so far none of
these projects have materialized well it
turns out that Pakistan produces a
little more than half of the gas that
consumes but the rest it has to import
and how does the gas get to Pakistan
exactly by a liquefied natural gas ships
and as you know liquefied natural gas is
much more expensive than pipeline gas
and in Pakistan there isn't exactly
money to spare Nationwide power blackout
plunges Pakistan Into Darkness but wait
a minute because this news is from
before the Ukraine war that is before
those LNG tankers turned around before
reaching the ports of Pakistan and went
to Europe so as you can imagine what's
happening now in the middle of 2022
massive blackouts skyrocketing Energy
prices and factories which are shutting
down conclusion all that talk of a
welfare state and a prosperous economy
that Imran Khan promised in the election
campaign seems like a bad joke meanwhile
creditors want their debts paid and
Pakistan has ended up devaluing its own
currency
[Music]
as you can see one US dollar has gone
from costing 100 rupees in 2017 to
costing more than twice as much in 2022.
the results even more inflation for the
already suffering Pakistani citizens if
you look closely Khan was accumulating
the same symptoms that Sri Lanka had
before collapsing and that we have
already talked about on this channel
high debt Sky High inflation devalued
currency and shortages so when it seemed
that Khan was incapable of solving all
the problems that were accumulating on
the 10th of April 2022 he was kicked out
and the difference with the other Prime
Ministers before him is that at least
they did not have accused him of
corruption but rather it was the
parliament itself that kicked him out
through a vote of no confidence this is
the first time in Pakistan that a prime
minister has been sacked in this way
since then Pakistan has had a caretaker
government in this case the center-right
Muslim League has returned to power they
have already said that they will not
call new elections until they have made
some reforms to stabilize the country
the new president shazbaz Sharif has a
colossal task ahead of him but now the
question is over to you how do you think
the new government will solve all these
problems what do you think his priority
should be will Pakistan end up like Sri
Lanka and if so what implications do you
think this will have for International
Security you can leave me your answers
in the comments below as always don't
forget here on visualpolitik we release
new videos every week so subscribe to
this Channel and the little bell button
down there so you don't miss any of our
updates if you like this video like it
so we know and I'll see you next time
[Music]